padam marianne dubois ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre et j'y
associe mon collègue jean pierre door la
crise agricole d'une ampleur inédite
sans racines avec comme fertilisant
l'accumulation de mauvaises nouvelles
toutes les filières sont touchées aucun
département n'était pas renié et je
pense au loiret très mobilisés
aujourd'hui
certes des mesures ont été prises mais
ce ne sont pas les millions d'euros ni
les reports divers et variés que qui
feront l'avenir de notre agriculture
nous avons besoin de la mobilisation de
l'ensemble de votre gouvernement
et permettez-moi quelques suggestions
avant le remaniement annoncé
nous aurions besoin d'un ministre très
volontaire des affaires européennes à
bruxelles pour en finir avec le dumping
social et tendre enfin vers une
harmonisation européenne
nous aurions besoin d'un ministre des
affaires étrangères habile pour
retrouver nos marchés à l'export et
notamment en russie
nous aurions besoin d'un ministre des
finances efficace pour activer les
leviers redonnant de la compétitivité au
secteur agricole
elle lui permettre de bénéficier du cic
e et de la baisse des charges nous
aurions besoin d'un ministre de
l'économie courageux qui se penchent
efficacement sur les clauses
renégociation et leur relation
producteurs transformateurs
distributeurs
enfin nous aurions besoin d'un vrai
ministre de l'agriculture qui
simplifierait qui simplifierait les
transpositions de règles communautaires
et toutes les normes et mesures ayant
des impacts très négatifs surtout besoin
d'un ministre à temps plein qui ne se
consacrerait cas ces dossiers et à la
valorisation des produits français
mon propos est amère mais je n'ai pas
l'habitude de poser des questions sur ce
ton mais nos campagnes nos campagnes
désespéré le mérite
monsieur le premier ministre combien de
croix blanches faudra-t-il encore sur le
parvis de la basilique de sainte anne
d'auray pour que vous preniez enfin la
mesure de la situation
merci madame dubois la parole est à
monsieur stéphane le foll mini jack et
culture d'algues jaunes président madame
la députée vous n'avez pas l'habitude de
poser ce type de questions mais je vais
vous répondre
nous aurions eu effectivement besoin
d'un ministre européen qui ne cède pas
lorsqu'on a voulu abandonner les quotas
laitiers
nous aurions eu besoin d'un ministre de
l'agriculture qui soit présent pour
défendre un budget de l'agriculture qui
permettent aujourd'hui aux agriculteurs
de toucher des aides légitime pour leur
travail
nous aurions eu besoin d'un ministre des
finances soutenu par une majorité à
l'époque qui ne laisse pas se mettre en
place une loi sur la lm eux qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes obligés de
subir la loi de la grande distribution
donc madame la députée lorsque vous
posez cette question il faut toujours
que vous ayez en tête ce que vous avez
fait pas ce qu'il faut pas aller à lire
aux agriculteurs aujourd'hui yann il
voulait une crise qui dépend
effectivement une situation de marché à
l'échelle européenne et à l'échelle
internationale sur la question de la
russie nous avons bien sûr travaillé
pour lever cet embargo
mais je voudrais rappeler un chiffre qui
vient de sortir de franceagrimer
aujourd'hui si on regarde la valeur
ajoutée qui est exporté par la filière
porcine française et par rapport à
l'espagne 70 centimes par kilo par
rapport à l'allemagne
55 centimes par kilo par rapport aux
pays bas
50 centimes par kilo par rapport à la
france 30 centimes par kilo si nous
n'avions eu un ministre de l'agriculture
qui ont été capables de structurer cette
filière ya quelques années nous n'en
serions pas là aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
allez merci la parole